[Musique]
le chômage les emplois précaires
l'absence d'avenir pour les jeunes toute
situation qui touche non seulement trois
millions quatre cent mille chômeurs mais
au total près de 5 millions de personnes
tout cela représente un drame jamais vu
dans ce pays une véritable catastrophe
nationale
d'autant que cela a des répercussions
dans de nombreux domaines et quoi qu'on
en dise cette situation ne va pas
s'améliorer même si ce qui semble se
passer depuis deux mois continuer le
chômage diminuerait que deux cent mille
personnes par an il faudrait 35 ans pour
le supprimer entièrement même les
promesses les plus électoralistes les
plans soi-disant les plus audacieux des
grands candidats envisagent de supprimer
que deux cent mille chômeurs par an y
compris le programme de jospin car la
réduction à 37 heures de la semaine de
travail n'amènerait que quatre cent
mille emplois supplémentaires en deux
ans même s'ils ont multiplié leurs
promesses par trois et à condition
qu'ils tiennent parole
il faudrait six ou dix ans pour donner
du travail aux chômeurs et aux jeunes
n'y at il pas là de quoi être indigné
car les chômeurs les exclus de cette
société de rapines
les jeunes ne peuvent pas attendre ni 15
ans ni cinq ans ni même deux ans car les
chômeurs sont menacés à court terme de
la misère et de l'exclusion et les
exclus sont menacés de la déchéance
physique et morale a bien plus brève
échéance encore face à cela les
scandales ont jeté un rai de lumière
encore bien trop faible sur la vie et le
luxe de certains hauts personnages de
l'état et de certains grands patrons qui
parfois sont les mêmes car il passe deux
ministres à pdg ou quad plus rarement de
pdg à ministre certains on a pu le voir
touchent des salaires avec lesquels on
pourrait faire vivre 40 à 200 smicards
ou le double de rmistes des ministres
des maires de grandes villes sont
accusés d'utilisation frauduleuse des
fonds publics
on voit des patrons de multinationales
être menacés des tribunaux comme le pdg
d'alcatel alsthom qui est soupçonné
d'avoir surfacturé des centraux
téléphoniques à l'état pur peut-être un
milliard de francs surfacturation peut
être permise par quelques pots de vin
distribués aux bons endroits
et bien pour lutter d'urgence contre le
chômage et l'exclusion
il faut éclairer mais éclairé largement
tout ce qui se passe dans les finances
des grandes entreprises et dans les
sommets de l'état il faut pouvoir
prendre l'argent là où il est pour cela
il faut rendre publiques les
comptabilités de toutes les grandes
entreprises
il faut que la presse y compris la
presse syndicale et la liberté de
publier leurs comptes afin de tout le
monde puisse savoir quelle est la part
des profits celle des salaires ce qui
est payé acquis que la presse puisse
publier les déclarations d'impôts de
tous les hommes politiques qui nous
gouvernent mais aussi sans être
poursuivi comme l'est le canard enchaîné
celle des grands patrons qui peuvent
décider de fermer une entreprise comme
on claque la porte de son réfrigérateur
et ruiné du même coup une ville ou une
région tout entière
il faut savoir où va l'argent
quand ils spéculent au lieu d'investir
et quand ils achètent des entreprises
ici ou à l'étranger que l'on sache pour
quoi faire et comment ils vont les
utiliser
il faut qu'il soit responsable devant le
pays
prenez l'exemple du crédit lyonnais
parce qu'un pdg a agi de façon
irresponsable
suivant les dires de son successeur
c'est plusieurs milliers d'employés du
crédit lyonnais qui risquent de perdre
leur emploi ou plusieurs milliers de
jeunes qui auraient pu être embauchés et
qui ne le seront pas même si ce pdg
condamné est-ce que cela rendra un
emploi à ceux qui vont le perdre
oui il faut rendre tous les comptes
publics
tous les comptes en banque tous les
avoirs les patrimoines de tous ces gens
là de l'inquisition cela une atteinte à
la liberté mais un patron n'a qu'à
s'adresser au service du personnel pour
savoir ce que gagne n'importe lequel de
ses salariés des manoeuvres aux cadres
mais lui quand on publie sa feuille
d'impôts ce serait une natte
quant à sa vie privée les licencieurs
eux portent atteinte à la vie privée de
milliers voire de dizaines de milliers
de travailleurs qu'ils ont eu la liberté
de jeter à la rue
aujourd'hui il faut que cela chance
d'urgence et il faut aussi réquisitionné
sans indemnité ni rachat
toutes les grandes entreprises qui ont
licencié alors qu'elles font d'énormes
bénéfices
[Musique]
rené piquet on ne parle pas beaucoup de
maastricht dans cette campagne est-ce
que ce traité aurait eu moins effet
qu'on avait a lancé non surtout pas que
chacun ou que beaucoup soit une europe
de plein emploi une robe la solidarité
une europe de la coopération c'est tout
à fait évident mais ça c'est totalement
incompatible avec le traité de
maastricht
c'est à dire la domination écrasante de
l'argent et la concurrence sauvage dont
on connaît ce qu'elle détruit dans notre
pays ont pour ce faire il faudrait parce
que je constate que c'est mme robert hue
le fait dire un non catégorique à
maastricht dans cette élection est
rassemblée regrouper pour travailler à
la construction d'une nouvelle europe
qui soit porteuse des aspirations des
habitants du pays puis tout simplement
des hommes de notre continent et sa
robert est le seul à l'exprimer dans
cette campagne électorale
robert hue quel rapport entre le rap et
vos propositions pour la france mais il
faut que les choses changent dans notre
pays la france a besoin d'une d'une
grande politique de l'emploi des
salaires de la protection sociale du
logement de de l'éducation et et rené
piquet a raison il faut choisir où une
politique de progrès social ou alors
c'est l'acceptation de la politique
d'austérité de chômage de masse triche
on dit que c'est impossible aujourd'hui
de remettre en cause ma ce triste mais
c'est déjà ce qu'en disait qu du général
de gaulle quand il a dit non aux
américains
et pourtant il a eu raison on peut quand
même être pour l'europe et et
contrebasse triche
l'europe c'est une idée extraordinaire
une belle idée mais il faut une europe
des peuples une europe des nations une
europe des coopérations pas celle qu'on
nous propose avec maastricht injustement
comme la france et l'europe ne sont pas
isolés du raisonnement quand vous faire
entendre l'appel lancé par george
harrison est le cri de colère de
aline pailler le président impasse la
situation s'aggrave dans l'outre-mer
elle est catastrophique
35 % de chômeurs une économie en ruine
une jeunesse de sang à venir c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous appelons les
populations de l'outre-mer a voté pour
mary seul son programme prend en compte
nos véritables revendications
c'est-à-dire la renégociation de nos
rapports avec l'europe une assemblée
unique et surtout davantage de pouvoirs
pour les élus de la martinique de la
guadeloupe de l'ensemble de l'outre-mer
donc le 23 avril toutes ces populations
doivent voter massivement pour mary
pour ma part je ne peux pas être
heureuse dans un monde en pleine
détresse je ne peux pas être heureuse
dans une forteresse et les communistes
non plus c'est pour ça que je suis avec
eux dans ce combat dans ce combat qui
dit que c'est insupportable que trois
millions d'enfants meurent de
malnutrition chaque année qu'un milliard
de personnes dans le monde vivent avec 5
francs par jour tout cela n'est pas dû
au hasard
c'est la mondialisation de l'économie
réelle ou financière c'est les lois du
marché qui deviennent le seul arbitre et
bien nous nous voulons changer cette
logique pour être heureux dans un monde
en en réaction revenus bon je les
remercie de de leur appel
ils ont raison d'être révolté regarder
tant de milliards de d'êtres humains qui
qui qui ont qu'il faut tendre richesse
pour des milliers de deux puissants qui
eux bénéficient de la fortune tout ça
est insupportable pourquoi cette
situation elle ne doit rien à la
fatalité
ces peuples sont littéralement étranglé
piller aujourd'hui est ce que ce sont
les peuples des pays riches qui en
profitent qu'il est pire
bien sûr que non ce sont qui pillent ce
sont les banques ce sont les affairistes
internationaux voilà c'est ça la réalité
est ce que c'est possible de faire
autrement aujourd'hui
regardez le premier commerce dans le
monde c'est le commerce des armes
le second commerce celui de la drogue ce
monde et il marche sur la tête
il faut d'autres rapports internationaux
des rapports d'abord il faut taxer les
capitaux spéculatifs qui s'enrichissent
de la misère du tiers-monde piermont il
faut lui donner les moyens de développer
sa propre économie de manière à ce qu
ils puissent coopérer lui aussi voyez
vous c'est ça et me pensais que la
france aujourd'hui tout seul là il peut
peser sur ses rapports internationaux
qui existent tout seul évidemment pas
mais mais en tous les cas ce qu il faut
bien avoir en tête c'est que la france
elle compte dans le monde ça compte la
france dans le monde
elle peut jouer un rôle très différent
de celui qu'elle joue aujourd'hui un
grand rôle pour le désarmement pour la
paix prod et des coopérations voyez vous
entre pour l'amitié entre les peuples
je crois que ce sont de grandes
ambitions que nous devons avoir notre
pop sa jeunesse
bon ben ils peuvent entreprendre de
grandes choses comme celles là
[Musique]
solidarité la vérité elle est d'arrêter
démocratie encrassent les mots kraft et
mocratie fraternité parité parité et
théologiques et comique de soleil
je me souviens qu'en 1974 j'en ai dumont
qui était le premier candidat écologiste
à l'élection présidentielle était venu
sur le plateau avec un verre d'eau il
avait dit aux français vous voyez ce
bien que vous croyez facile d'accès il
usa bhl il suffit de tourner le robinet
etc on va peut-être manquer bientôt je
crois qu'il avait raison vingt ans plus
tard on se rend bien compte de l'aspect
un peu prophétique du travail de rené
dumont à l'époque par exemple il y à
beaucoup de pays où on a développé des
programmes formidable d'irrigation pour
permettre de développer une agriculture
très intensive destinée à l'exportation
et dans ces pays on n'est souvent pas en
mesure de garantir un bon niveau
d'alimentation aux populations autre
exemple ce qui s'est passé après la
guerre du golfe dans les pays du
moyen-orient la guerre pour l'eau était
un risque
une menace qui continuent d'ailleurs à
peser sur cette région ici même il ya
plusieurs millions de personnes qui
n'ont pas accès à une eau de qualité qui
respecte les normes de potabilité défini
au niveau européen
la pollution de l'eau par les nitrates
par l'atrazine par des régimes métaux
lourds que je vais vous dire mais
souvent en cause les paysans et leurs
jambes le etc
mais les paysans ne sont pas seulement
coupables ils sont aussi les victimes
d'une logique productiviste qui les
force à produire toujours plus les
aliments de qualité de plus en plus
hasardeuses
sans même réussir à sortir un revenu
décent de leur travail
moi je pense qu'il faut changer les
règles du jeu installer des paysans
nombreux sur tout le territoire et dans
les zones de montagne notamment mais
aussi changer le système de fixation des
prix agricoles pour qu'ils puissent
vivre dignement sans polluer au coeur de
cette pop haye pour pour tout le monde
pour tous les candidats au coeur des
préoccupations des gens bien sûr il ya
le chômage alors je propose trois choses
fortes
les 35 heures tout de suite pour aller
dans les 30 heures à la fin du siècle
j'ai été heureuse de voir que bien des
syndicalistes reprenait cette idée est
que le plus grand syndicat de france
saluait finalement notre engagement dans
cette direction deuxième proposition la
création d'un milieu d'un million
d'emplois dans des secteurs qui
correspondent à des besoins qui sont
nier aujourd'hui dans le cadre de
l'économie de marché dans le domaine de
l'écologie sociale domaine social ce
million d'emplois il pourrait être
viabilisés pérenniser grâce aux sommes
formidables collectées par l'unedic pour
indemniser les chômeurs et puis je crois
aussi indispensable de revoir ce qu'est
un contrat cs ça ne doit pas remplacer
des emplois statutaires c'est pourquoi
je demande la transformation des 700 ou
800 mille postes cs dans les services
publics et les collectivités locales en
poste statutaire et rs qu' il ya un
autre domaine aussi qui est très
préoccupant pour les gens et qui vous
touche tout particulièrement vous
puisque vous êtes médecin
c'est le problème de la santé et
notamment ce fameux trou de la sécurité
sociale est ce que demain on pourra
continuer à garantir le système de
protection de chemin actuel aux français
je crois qu'il faut le réaffirmer
clairement il est hors de question de
toucher à la sécu c'est un acquis
collectifs formidable et nous faisons
aujourd'hui en 95
comme il ya cinquante ans le choix de la
solidarité et de la répartition juste
des richesses
alors moi je pense qu'il faut le
rappeler le trou de la sécu il est pour
l'essentiel liée au chômage résoudre le
problème du chômage c'est aussi
permettre à la sécu de survivre et puis
je crois qu'il faut unifier les
différents régimes de protection sociale
et reconnaître à chacun le droit
assurance à l'assurance maladie sur
simple déclaration de résidence enfin
dernier mot parce que c'est aussi une
des préoccupations coeur de votre
campagne
les rapports nord-sud les rapports avec
les pays qu'on dit en voie de
développement qui en fait s'enfonce le
plus souvent dans la misère le sommet de
rio il y a deux ans avait donné
l'impression que les grands pays
développés du nord étaient prêts à
prendre leurs responsabilités pour que
les pays du sud
et eux aussi droit à développement
équitable pour leur environnement et
pour leurs habitants deux ans plus tard
on se rend bien compte que les bonnes
intentions ne sont pas suivies d'effet
il faut absolument abolir la dette des
pays les moins avancés
et puis prendre la mesure de nos
gaspillages notamment en matière
d'énergie aujourd'hui par habitant ont
produit en france quatre fois de plus de
gaz à effet de serre qu en inde et on se
permet encore de donner des leçons à ses
peuples des pays en voie de
développement qui qui veulent accéder à
un minimum de bien-être aux et dominique
voynet
ça change tout
[Musique]
pour une france juste avec gagner de
gestion j'ai voulu que ces émissions
officielles soient fondés sur le
dialogue avec les français
c'est pourquoi vous êtes là et
aujourd'hui vous avez voulu parler de
l'emploi
oui les nages et 100 g 20 ans c'est la
première fois que je vote pour des
présidentielles et j'entends les
diverses campagnes les candidats qui
évidemment affirment qu'ils sont contre
le jeu le chômage et j'aimerais que vous
me donniez une bonne raison de voter
pour vous en ce qui concerne le chômage
je voudrais vous en donner plusieurs et
en même temps c'est logique les
candidats parlent du chômage parce que
c'est la préoccupation dominante des
français quand je dis plusieurs c'est
que je pense qu'il faut attaquer cet
incendie que le chômage par plusieurs
côtés je propose de le faire par la
diminution de la durée du travail
je propose de le faire par l'
augmentation maîtrisée des salaires
accroissant la consommation et offrant
des débouchés aux entreprises et donc
des emplois
je propose de le faire par quatre grands
programmes de création d'emplois et
aussi par la diminution des charges sur
les bas salaires
vous proposez 37 eur en 1997 mais est ce
que réellement ce sera suffisant pour
créer les emplois des experts
indépendants viennent de chiffrer ces
mesures à 400000 emplois en deux ans 200
mille par an c'est donc efficace mais
effectivement il faudra aller plus loin
j'ai visité par exemple une entreprise
d'une fonderie dans l'ouest qui a passé
un accord avec les salariés qui descend
en dessous de 37 heures et sans
diminution de salaire
moi je fixe un cap en tant que président
de la république et je laisse les
entreprises négocier les branches
négocier au niveau du patronat et des
salariés
mais en dix ans la durée légale passera
à 37 heures en 1997 après il faudra
aller plus loin sans doute vers la
semaine de 4 jours ce cric créera des
emplois mais aussi offrira du temps de
vivre
vous parlez de 400000 emplois créés et
je suis chômeuse comme plus de trois
millions de personnes dans ce pays et je
me demande si ce n'est pas une goutte
d'eau dans la mer
c'est une grosse goutte d'eau quand même
que quatre cent mille emplois mais en
même temps ça ne suffit pas c'est
pourquoi je propose d'autres modes
d'action je les dis quatre grands
programmes de création d'emplois
impulsée par l'état qui met de l'argent
qui trouve des relais dans les
entreprises mais aussi dans les
collectivités locales dans le domaine de
la lutte contre
l'habitat dégradé pour le logement
social dans le domaine des emplois de
proximité dans le domaine de
l'environnement dans le domaine de
l'humanitaire l'extérieur de la france
où en france et ce seront des vrais
emplois des emplois à statut pas des
boulots précaires comme la droite semble
se satisfaire d'avoir de nombreux
français restent sceptiques
comment peut-on à la fois réduire le
temps de travail et augmenter les
salaires
regardez on est en train de le faire en
allemagne dans la métallurgie ou un
accord vient d'être signé
35 heures au mois d'octobre et
progression des salaires modérés sur
deux ans je crois qu'on peut faire de
même pourquoi parce que la productivité
augmente chaque année dans les
entreprises les machines peuvent tourner
davantage même si les hommes et les
femmes travaillent moins donc on on peut
le faire ça peut être efficace et de
toute façon les entreprises ayant
restauré quand même beaucoup leur profit
leurs marges
il faut que les salariés qui ont fait
des efforts et notamment les petits
salaires ceux qui sont au smic profitent
des fruits de la croissance donc je suis
pour une augmentation générale
maîtrisait des salaires notamment avec
un effort sur les bas salaires
lionel jospin je suis surpris pourquoi
lorsque la gauche était au pouvoir
pourquoi n'at-elle pas réalisé la
réduction du temps de travail on a
l'impression que c'est une solution
miracle qui surgit comme ça à la veille
de l'élection présidentielle sans doute
parce que on était concentrés dans la
lutte contre l'inflation la hausse des
prix nos entreprises qui n'étaient pas
assez efficace notre déficit du commerce
extérieur
et même si on a diminué d'une heure la
durée du travail de 40 à 39 heures
on s'est concentré sur autre chose mais
le chômage envahi tellement notre
société et l'exclusion et la précarité
qu'il faut centrer l'action maintenant
dans la lutte pour l'emploi c'est ma
priorité première
je voudrais vous poser une question que
j'aimerais bien posée aux autres
candidats aussi qui va financer tout
cela
moi je les chiffres et dans des
propositions qui ont été jugés je crois
réaliste il ya naturellement les fruits
de la croissance qui apportent des
recettes mais il ya surtout que je fais
une réforme fiscale et je fais payer
davantage le capital qui jusqu'ici paye
moins que les autres pays européens
je crois que c'est juste et je crois que
ce sera efficace pour le financement de
l'emploi et de l'activité économique
ma priorité essentielle c'est l'emploi
je pense que si
l'état se mobilise les pouvoirs publics
mais si les entreprises aussi se met en
mouvement les collectivités locales
l'ensemble de la collectivité nationale
on peut être efficace pour créer des
emplois et commencer à améliorer la
situation dans notre pays tous ensemble
une france plus juste avec gagnac
gestion
[Musique]
alors
ce sont les valeurs de la république
c'est l'égalité des droits à l'égalité
des chances la juste récompense du
mérite et du travail c'est la solidarité
c'est la laïcité c'est la tolérance
[Musique]
alors je m'attèle philippe lambert je
suis comptable chez 26 ans
qu'est ce que le pacte républicain acte
républicain ça veut dire rassemblement
ça veut dire efforts pour faire en sorte
que la cohésion sociale de la société
française qui est menacée à cause de ces
5 millions d'exclus notamment qu'a
engendré le phénomène du chômage faire
en sorte donc que cette cohésion soit
préservée et renforcée et pour cela il
faut se situer un peu au dessus des
clivages traditionnels il faut essayer
de rechercher ce qui rassemble et non
pas ceux qui divisent
vous avez observé que depuis le début de
sa campagne jacques chirac parle des
valeurs c'est un mot qui avait un peu
disparu du langage politique il parle
des valeurs républicaines
l'égalité des chances la récompense du
mérite et de l'effort individuel mais
aussi la solidarité la tolérance la
laïcité et ces valeurs là on le voit
bien
elles sont au dessus des clivages
traditionnels elles ne sont ni de droite
ni de gauche
ce sont des valeurs de rassemblement
elle fonde le pacte républicain
[Musique]
pour soit et vous dire aux sceptiques
aux personnes qui pensent qu'on ne peut
rien changer aujourd'hui je souhaite
leur dire que si depuis le début de
l'humanité
on avait toujours tenu ce raisonnement
nous en serions toujours la cro magnon
en fait depuis le début de l'humanité
il a toujours fallu remettre en cause
l'ordre établi pour progresser donc je
crois que la vraie question c'est de
savoir si on a la volonté de le faire et
si ayant la volonté on en a les moyens
mais pas les moyens seulement techniques
financiers et budgétaires les moyens
humains et les moyens humains c'est quoi
c'est le courage et l'imagination et mon
sentiment qui me laissait que
aujourd'hui d'une certaine façon le
courage l'imagination ont déserté les
hommes politiques et les dirigeants se
dénude signa quelques années du temps où
c'était encore la russie soviétique
trouvé que les occidentaux ne faisait
rien pour libérer les peuples asservis
et il disait dans son grand discours
harvard que le courage avait déserté
l'occident et bien d'une certaine façon
aujourd'hui je crois que ce dont nous
avons besoin c'est que le courage habite
de nouveau nos coeurs et nos énergies
je pense que c'est ça que le peuple
attend de cette élection présidentielle
il attend que ça ne soit pas après
l'élection comme avant et pour que ce ne
soit pas après comme avant eh bien je
crois que ce qu'il faut d'abord c'est
que on est une volonté qu'on la met en
oeuvre à partir de beaucoup de courage
comme jacques chirac l'a fait quand il
ya deux ans personne ne croyait en lui
il ne s'est pas désunie il ne sait pas
désolé il n'a pas pleurnicher
il s'est pas mis à se lamenter en disant
tout le monde est méchant avec moi non
il a dit moi je connais ce que veulent
les français
j'ai le sentiment profond de leurs
besoins de leurs aspirations alors je
vais essayer de faire quelque chose et
puis aujourd'hui les français disent oui
on est d'accord pour le faire annuler
[Musique]
je m'appelle michel pasquet je suis
étudiant en médecine à à bobigny comment
pensez vous mettre fin à la mainmise des
politiques sur les médias la réponse est
laid comme dans tous les domaines c'est
le pluralisme qui n'entend qu'une cloche
n'entend qu'un son et c'est ce que dit
la sagesse populaire et donc il faut
qu'on puisse écouter toutes les pensées
toutes les paroles que chacun puisse
s'exprimer
et dans cette campagne un exemple
seulement formidable c'est vrai que
pendant les médias ont donné le
sentiment que la campagne se réduisait
ya d'un côté une candidature de gauche
de témoignage parce que la gauche
personne n'en voulait et de l'autre côté
un premier ministre candidat officiel
qui allait passer de la rive gauche à la
rive droite et d'un fauteuil à matignon
à un fauteuil à l'elysée mais comme par
une espèce de formalité électorale et
les français ont dit mais nous c'est pas
ça l'élection présidentielle c'est mou
nous voulons utiliser l'élection
présidentielle pour faire changer les
choses
et comme au même moment jacques chirac
leur dise exactement la même chose
ils ont dit lui il nous prend vraiment
au sérieux et c'est comme ça qu'on a
brisé si j'ose dire
le conformisme des médias donc je pense
que il ya deux réponses
la première réponse et assurer le
pluralisme et la deuxième réponse c'est
dire des choses vraies et forte
et quand on dit des choses vraies forte
et bien finissent toujours par passer
[Musique]
je suis candidat à la présidence de la
république pour répondre au besoin
d'espoir et de changement des françaises
et des français
[Musique]
vous vous rendez compte de ce que c'est
que d'avoir 20 ans aujourd'hui est
d'avoir deux chances sur trois
patrouilles du travail oui je m'en rends
compte et je m'en rends même tellement
content que c'est pour cela que j'ai
placé l'emploi et l'action en faveur de
la jeunesse
parmi les priorités de mon action future
d'ores et déjà il y a moins de jeunes au
chômage qu'il n'y en avait il ya deux
ans mais ce n'est pas assez il y en a
beaucoup trop et ce qu'il faut c'est
développer la formation de la jeunesse
de façon pratique concrète pour qu'elle
débouche sur des emplois
ce qu'il faut c'est aider les
entreprises à recruter des jeunes comme
nous l'avons prévu par des aides
particulières
lorsqu'elles recrutent un jeune tout ce
que nous ferons pour développer l'emploi
en france et nous avons commencé à
obtenir des résultats il faudra que nous
allions beaucoup plus loin
j'ai dit au moins un million de chômeurs
de moins dans les cinq ans qui viennent
et peut-être davantage
tout ce que nous ferons c'est à la
jeunesse qu'en premier lieu cela
profitera n'y a rien de plus important
que de rendre l'espoir à la jeunesse je
le répète mon job chez balladur
l'apprentissage s'est s'allié au
centquatre est bien sûr que c'est
sérieux
vous ne devez pas en douter c'est
tellement peu un gadget que nous l'avons
développée de 25% depuis deux ans et
qu'il n'ya plus d'apprentis aujourd'hui
qu'il n'y en a eu depuis 25 ans dans
notre pays
pourquoi est-ce que c'est sérieux parce
que ça consiste à apprendre aux jeunes
grâce aux aides que nous avons donné aux
entreprises à apprendre jeunes leurs
métiers dans l'entreprise j'ai visité
l'autre jour un centre d'apprentissage
dans l'essonne dans la région parisienne
les 500 jeunes une semaine dans
l'entreprise une semaine en formation
une semaine dans l'entreprise une
semaine en formation et tous étaient
très contents car il avait le sentiment
que ça déboucher sur quelque chose de
concret les moniteurs étaient très
contents et les entreprises l'était
aussi
c'est donc une chose qu'il faut
développer monsieur balladur vous parler
de l'égalité des chances
croyez vous vraiment que ça puisse
exister vous avez raison de vous
interroger
je veux tout faire pour un croître
l'égalité des chances dans notre pays
notamment en faveur des jeunes
ça veut dire développer leur formation
ça veut dire développer les bourses et
maintenir le droit la bourse même quand
on change l'orientation qu'on est
obligés de redoubler ça veut dire
garantir à chaque jeune de moins de 20
ans qui leur a soit un emploi soit une
formation
ça veut dire garantir à chaque jeune de
moins de 26 ans qu'il pourra faire un
stage dans une entreprise s'il ne l'a
pas fait
l'égalité des chances est une recherche
constante et que nous devons garantir à
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens et aux
jeunes en particulier avant qu'il ne
démarre dans la vie
qu'est ce que c'est que la deuxième
chance c'est lutter contre l'injustice
quand on a pris un mauvais départ dans
la vie il faut pouvoir se récupérer
c'est à dire avoir la garantie que l'on
pourra faire des études complémentaires
jeu jusqu'à trois ans en conservant une
rémunération pour faire vivre sa famille
et en conservant son lien avec
l'entreprise
c'est une véritable révolution ça voudra
dire qu'on vit dans une société plus
juste où chacun a sa chance
on vous entend pas beaucoup parler du
sida je trouve ne croyez pas ça j'en
parle mais je fais mieux j'agis et nous
avons beaucoup travaillé depuis deux ans
il faut aller plus loin car je comprends
l'angoissé la jeunesse il faut supprimer
tout risque de contamination par
transfusion sanguine
il faut diminuer encore davantage le
risque de contamination par voie
sexuelle et développer la distribution
de préservatifs dans les établissements
d'enseignement
il faut faire en sorte que les places
d'hôpitaux soient plus abondante la
lutte contre le sida est désormais une
priorité
l'espoir c'est quoi aujourd'hui
pour les jeunes aujourd'hui l'espoir
c'est croire que l'avenir sera meilleur
que le présent et c'est ce que je veux
que les jeunes est une meilleure
formation qu'ils accèdent à l'emploi
plus facilement qu'ils puissent créer
une famille s'il le désire qu'ils se
sentent à l'aise dans une société bien
préparé pour eux nous avons fait des
progrès depuis deux ans désormais on
peut en faire de beaucoup plus rapide
pour faire en sorte que la jeunesse est
toute sa place dans notre société
je ne promets que ce que je pourrais
tenir la politique pour moi c'est la
vérité
[Musique]
françaises français quand on a des
enfants tout jeune comme c'est mon cas
on est peut-être plus sensibilisé plus
inquiets devant les immenses problèmes
qui les assaillent le problème de la
drogue qui nous envahit alors que la
france vient de faire disparaître ses
frontières ce qui est irresponsable et
le problème de la corruption
le danger c'est le regard de dérision
porté sur la politique il faut
réhabiliter la politique donné la
dépendance à la justice lutter contre
l'insécurité à rétablir l'autorité de
l'état la sécurité en france c'est un
vrai problème
vous prenez tous les jours la télévision
les journaux ne se passe pas une journée
sans que l'on parle de la délinquance ou
des vols qui sont en augmentation en
france depuis quelques jours les
frontières de nos pays sont ouvertes
là je pense que notre pays je suis
inquiet va devenir une vraie passoire
moi je crois que ce monsieur a tout à
fait raison et j'ajouterais ceci pour
l'information des français je suis le
seul candidat dans la majorité à ne pas
avoir voté ratifié le fameux traité de
schengen qui a fait disparaître nos
frontières le 25 mars dernier
comment les autres candidats peuvent-ils
parler de la sécurité des français de la
nécessité de lutter contre l'immigration
clandestine
alors qu'ils ont ratifié la disparition
de nos frontières terrestres alors
qu'ils savent que nous savons
je l'apprends aux français qu'il ne
serait pas que 80 % des immigrants
clandestins qui ont été interpellées en
france ont été interpellés à nos
frontières terrestres si je suis élu
présent la république je rétablirai les
contrôles aux frontières de la france
[Musique]
savez vous si mère de famille la drogue
ça me fait vraiment peur pour mes
enfants
elle est partout c'est plus le phénomène
des grandes villes c'est vraiment un
fléau que pouvez vous faire pour
protéger nos enfants
certainement pas légaliser la drogue
certainement pas abandonner les drogués
certainement pas faire ce qu'a fait le
ministère de la santé en mettant la
méthadone remboursés par la sécurité
sociale à la disposition des drogués
certainement pas faire ce que fait la
ville de paris en distribuant des
seringues
pourquoi parce que ça ça veut dire on
lâche prise
ça c'est un signe qu'on donne à la fois
aux trafiquants et à ceux qui en sont
les victimes à la guerre on fait la
guerre
moi je veux faire la guerre aux
trafiquants en contrôlant nos frontières
parce que la drogue étant encline aux
pays bas et en aidant les blessés à la
guerre on n'abandonne pas les blesser
une société qui tiennent bull c'est une
société qui fait comme un père une mère
de famille quand on voit quelqu'un qui
tombe on le rattrape on le prend dans
ses bras et on lui dit on va te sortir
de là
[Musique]
moi je suis retraité j'aimerais vous
parler de la corruption je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui c'est une honte de voir
la corruption de s'installe partout et
comment on la traite
un automobiliste qui va qui aurait dû à
faire une infraction au code de la route
il sera condamné il paiera une amende
alors que certains hommes politiques ne
sont ni poursuivis ni qu'on allait
prenons l'exemple du crédit lyonnais qui
c'est qui va payer c'est du tous la
corruption ça coûte très cher aux
entreprises aux consommateurs aux
contribuables
les hommes politiques ont la charge de
gérer l'argent des contribuables il faut
donc qu'il soit irréprochable
nous sommes en droit vous êtes en droit
de l'exiger et c'est la raison pour
laquelle par mesure de prudence je
conseille aux français de faire appel à
quelqu'un 9 moi je propose
d'indépendance de la justice
je propose concret des juridictions
financières pour lutter contre les
nouvelles formes de la grande
délinquance économique et financière
je propose que soit inéligible à vie
ceux qui ont triché et qu' il soit
obligé de rembourser ce qu'ils ont volé
c'est de cette manière qu'on rétablira
la confiance entre les élus et les
citoyens
l'honnêteté le civisme un nouveau regard
sur l'avenir de la france
[Musique]
je vais essayer de vous expliquer ce que
certains journalistes parisiens
prétendent que les maires de communes
rurales et vous même ne pouvait pas
comprendre
il s'agit du lien entre la crise
financière internationale
est ce que vous éprouvez dans votre vie
quotidienne vous en avez pourtant tous
les jours des exemples
c'est l'école qui ferment l'épicerie la
pharmacie la boulangerie la maternité
qui s'en vont je vous en donne un
exemple encore plus révélateur
celui des deux agriculteurs un
agriculteur qui à partir de 1983 jusqu'à
aujourd'hui aurait travaillé sur son
exploitation est bien celui là il aurait
perdu environ 20 % de son investissement
pourquoi ils auraient payé des impôts
ils auraient payé des intérêts et le
prix de la terre surtout à baisser il
aurait perdu de l'argent en travaillant
l'autre qui en 1983 aurait vendu son
exploitation est investi sur la bourse
de paris sur le cac 40
celui là est bien il aurait gagné assez
aujourd'hui pour acheter trois ou quatre
exploitations cela une économie
d'injustice c'est cela une économie de
jeu car il ya un grand jeu au niveau
international qui est celui des marchés
dérivés sur lesquels on peut jouer
jusqu'à cent fois sa mise
celui du trafic de drogue celui de
l'immobilier et puis il y à un petit jeu
celui avec lesquels on cherche à nous
étourdir à nous distraire de la crise
le petit jeu à gratter et a tiré
et bien non il faut une autre politique
il faut un autre monde
il faut un nouveau plan marshall qui
rétablisse une politique une économie de
la croissance ou l'argent aille à la
production ou l'argent aille au travail
un nouveau plan marshall s'est organisé
des crédits à long terme est faible taux
d'intérêt pour créer des infrastructures
pour construire des ports des ponts des
routes et voies ferrées des trains à
grande vitesse est alors oui on a dans
une économie la structure le socle la
base à partir de laquelle on peut
assurer le développe je vous montre ici
une carte de l'europe une carte de
l'eurasie l'on voit là les voies ferrées
a su
l'irrigation de ces terres que se
permettre ainsi un progrès mutuelle
désenclaver ouvrir cela qu'il faut faire
à l'intérieur de notre europe celle des
seize aussi vers l'europe orientale et
vers l'afrique et ainsi nous rétablirons
ces conditions d'une paix par le
développement économique mutuelle mais
pour cela pour que cette politique
nouvelle puisse démarrer
il faut que l'état reprenne en main les
moyens d'émettre de la monnaie et du
crédit
l'état doit abolir l'autonomie la banque
de france l'état doit faire baisser les
taux d'intérêt et surtout il doit
revenir à une conception de la
planification qui soit cette ardente
obligation dont parlait pierre macé
louis armand et de gaulle
alors oui on pourra sortir de la crise
et rétablir l'espérance je vais vous
parler maintenant du nucléaire qui pour
moi est une part de cette aventure a
retrouvé
palluel la mer la normandie le nucléaire
le nucléaire je veux en parler dans ma
campagne en pensant à pierre et marie
curie à frédéric joliot curie à paul
langevin
après 1945 ceux qui avaient participé à
cette aventure
voyez dans le nucléaire un instrument
qui permettrait le développement du
tiers monde qui permettrait plus de
justice pour les pays du sud après le
nucléaire a été dénaturé les militaires
s'en sont emparés et on fait des atomes
pour la paix des atomes pour la guerre
l'eau n'a usé du nucléaire et abusé du
nucléaire en faisant parfois n'importe
quoi de ce point de vue je suis tout à
fait choqués scandalisés que la
communauté européenne n'est pas encore
pris les mesures pour fermer tchernobyl
pour assurer qu'on mette un point final
à ces errements le nucléaire aussi c'est
quelque chose qui ne peut pas se faire
dans un seul pays
il faut qu'entre pays du monde il y ait
une coopération pour le bien commun une
entente pour le bien commun
cet enthousiasme de l' aventure du
nucléaire à ses débuts
c'est ce qu'il nous faut retrouver
[Musique]
le pen
mes chers compatriotes bonjour le 23
avril de votre décision va dépendre
l'avenir de la france et donc des
français car il n'y aurait plus de
français si la france essaie d'exister
en tant que nation de tous les grands
candidats je suis le seul qui refusent
la logique qui conduit la france à
renoncer à sa souveraineté
peut-être de façon irrémédiable les
trois candidats maastricht y un jospin
balladur chirac vous promettent de
mettre en oeuvre des solutions miracle à
tous vos problèmes mais ils veulent
déléguée à une instance européenne les
pouvoirs et donc les moyens d'action du
président de la république française ce
que je vous propose moi c'est d'affirmer
et de reconquérir la souveraineté
française
ce que je vous propose c'est de bâtir
une france maîtresse d'elle même et de
son avenir et de ses lois
comment peut-on accepter que nous aurons
un règlement ou un traité international
nous interdisent par exemple de rétablir
la peine de mort ou de baisser les
impôts
la loi française doit être fait en
france et non à bruxelles ou ailleurs la
france doit rester maîtresse de sa
monnaie c'est à dire de son économie nos
compatriotes pêcheurs agriculteurs
ouvriers
ce dont les entreprises ont fermé leurs
portes pour s'installer dans les pays du
tiers monde sont appelés à leurs dépens
que le sens des français n'émeut guère
les technocrates européens abdiqué notre
souveraineté monétaire
c'est renoncer à agir nous mêmes contre
le chômage qui frappe 6 millions de nos
compatriotes et jette à la rue ou à la
misère un nombre croissant de français
pour agir efficacement en faveur du
plein emploi
le franc doit donc rester la monnaie des
français
la france doit aussi rester maîtresse de
ses frontières qui sont ses seules
protections contre les vagues
d'immigration venue du tiers-monde
contre le trafic de drogue lempire du
crime et les mafias de toutes sortes ou
contre la subversion de notre marché
intérieur par des produits importés à
bas prix président de la république je
dénoncerai les accords qui ouvre notre
pays à tous les vents et joe rétablir et
le contrôle de nos frontières nationales
la loi française doit s'appliquer sur
tout le territoire aux antilles on peut
désir nouvelle calédonie en guyane dans
l'océan indien ou en corse
elle doit s'appliquer aussi dans toutes
nos cités y compris certaines banlieues
qui sont aujourd'hui de véritables zones
de non droit la restauration d'un état
impartial et respecté peu seule garantir
aux français la paix civile
l'exercice de leurs libertés
individuelles politiques et économiques
leur permettent de conserver leur
patrimoine matériel culturel et
spirituel
la france doit rester maîtresse de sa
diplomatie et de sa défense
permettez moi ici d'avoir une pensée
pour ces mères françaises qui sur simple
décision du président américain ou le
secrétaire général de l'onu ont vu leurs
enfants partir et quelquefois mourir
dans des guerres qu'ils n'étaient pas
les nôtres la france est grande et
respecté dans le monde quand elle fait
entendre sa voix pas quand elle s'aligne
c'est pourquoi la france doit
reconstituer une armée forte et
puissante capable de se faire respecter
à travers le monde et grâce à nos
compatriotes des départements et
territoires d'outre-mer la france pour
enrayer au nez sur plus de 10 millions
de kilomètres carrés de zones maritimes
avons nous le droit de renoncer à notre
grandeur bien sûr que non mes chers
compatriotes notre salut ne viendra que
de nous mêmes
ceux qui veulent vous engager sur des
voies différentes
au nom d'une utopie ou par manque de
volonté condamne les français à n'être
que les spectateurs
les voyeurs de leur propre déclin et
peut-être même dans l'avenir des
esclaves
c'est parce que je suis attachée à la
défense de notre patrie à l'unité de la
république et à ses principes fondateurs
c'est parce que je refuse la loi de la
world company de ce nouvel ordre mondial
que certains lobbys veulent nous imposer
que je suis victime de toutes les
attaques
c'est parce que je suis patriote que je
veux une france forte belle rayonnante
et généreuse
en politique il n'y a pas de fatalité à
nous de prendre notre destin en main
voici venu le temps de la reconquête
c'est là mon message d'espoir lorsque le
vent se lève lorsque le ciel s'obscurcit
si et que la tempête menace il faut
d'abord un capitaine qui tiennent la
barre solidement faites moi confiance
français d'abord
français toujours
français passionnément
[Musique]